art has a very high status in modern
societies people flock to museums an
artworks fetch record prices but our age
is also oddly reluctant to say in clear
terms what art might actually be for an
odd mystique surrounds it epitomized by
the puzzlement many of us feel as we
look at yet another odd-looking modern
work of art in a contemporary Museum
we're often left quietly and politely
wondering what is it all meant to be
about for most of history this kind of
question didn't arise because it was
abundantly clear what art was for the
question mark over the purpose of art is
really a modern one so let's go back in
time and find out about a wider range of
options that we might be able to draw on
fruitfully today Rome - 90 AD deep below
the Imperial Roman City the faithful
secretly gather in catacombs or burial
chambers to celebrate new religious
figure Jesus Christ
Christianity though still in its infancy
and ruthlessly persecuted by the Roman
authorities is rapidly gaining ground
like so many religions before it and
since Christianity has become involved
with the making of art here an unnamed
and not especially talented artist
represents Jesus's healing of a bleeding
woman an incident recorded in the New
Testament like all religions
Christianity is using art for a clear
and understandable purpose to make its
message more resonant emotionally
attractive and popularly appealing art
is like a kind of advertising for its
ideas soon Christian artists are going
to dominate Europe for almost a thousand
years almost all art produced in Europe
will simply be Christian art from humble
beginnings in a subterranean prayer room
Christian art will go on to produce
extraordinary cathedrals paintings
sculptures and celebrating and enhancing
the prestige of its messages Thailand 15
century an unknown craftsman finishes a
statue of the Buddha one of many
hundreds of thousands of such statues
produced over the centuries in Southeast
Asia the purpose of such art is
extremely clear you're meant to look at
the Buddha and take inspiration becoming
a little more as he is the sculpture is
an invitation to calm and contemplation
in the east as in the West Art's
function is evident to support the
truths set down by religions to make
ideas more easily digestible Paris
January 1801 the French artist Jack lui
devide finishes Napoleon crossing the
Alps it commemorates a moment when a
couple of years before Napoleon still in
his 20s launched a lightning raid on the
north Italian States winning a series of
astonishing victories in the picture
napoleon masters a white warhorse though
he actually crossed the mountains on a
more serviceable mule here art is doing
something it has done throughout history
as well acting as propaganda for a
political cause Napoleon is looking back
to the example of louis xiv of france
who did a lot of propagandizing with art
it was a habit he got into throughout
his rule paris 1833 the poet novelist
and critic tearful gucci publishes an
essay about art which argues that art
must free itself from the poisonous
agendas of religions and governments the
point of good art is always to be just
for its own sake as he put it in French
la polla art for art's sake this
doctrine of art for art's sake becomes
the motto of the new generation of
romantic artists who set themselves
against the old ideal that art should
serve religion nor powerful rulers or
nations nonsense says gucci true art
must serve nothing at all it is an end
in itself and doesn't try to change or
do or speak about anything artists set
themselves apart from the bourgeois
commercial society growing up all around
which is always trying to sell people
things art should try to inhabit a
loftier
abstract realm New York 1917 the artist
Marcel Duchamp prepares to exhibit his
latest work at a show by the Society of
independent artists it is surprisingly a
urinal title simply fountain Duchamp is
in rebellion against many notions of
what art is that it should be easy to
understand that it should make sense
that it should promote something the
true artists argues do Shaw must defend
himself against any confusion with
advertising mass media government
propaganda or religious indoctrination
the true purpose of the artist is to
stand outside the mainstream and create
works that are enigmatic mysteriously
provocative and rather silent New York
1949 a Russian emigre artist
Marcus Roth kovitch who has renamed
himself Mark Rothko to escape
anti-semitism exhibits a new range of
works at the Betty Parsons gallery in
Manhattan they are a revelation in that
they seem not to be about anything they
are about pure color fields and are as
abstract as music for some they are the
greatest works of the 20th century and
soon fetch enormous prices the Museum of
Modern Art acquires a major set of
Rothko's as do other national museums
around the world
Rothko becomes representative of the
more obscure direction of 20th century
art highly appealing to an elite who
will often pay enormous incomprehensible
prices for works but puzzling for the
wider public Venice June 2005 the
world's most prestigious Art Fair the
Venice Biennale opens at the newly
restored spaces of the arson alley it
has been curated for the first time by
two women Maria de Corral and Rosa
Martinez 41 artists are shown from all
over the world the nearby Marco Polo
Airport is filled with the private jets
of the world's billionaires many of whom
professed to love art elaborate cocktail
parties are held late into the night art
has become a playground for the
super-rich as well as an obligatory
tourist destination for weary travelers
art is both hugely revered and yet
somehow still in question for most of
its history art has been saddled with a
mission to glorify religion or to speak
well of the state modern art was the
result of a swerve away from these
Aegean
for extremely understandable reasons yet
if art is to regain its true centrality
it should overcome it hesitation about
stating what it's really for and is
trying to do it is really and has always
been a sophisticated tool a tool that
can help us to cope with things like
loneliness that can fill us with hope
that can help us to communicate are in a
world that questions power and aims to
improve political systems it is never an
insult to ask art to do things for us to
be a practical part of our daily lives
we honor art most when we give it the
highest task of all to help us to lead
better lives
if you like our films take a look at our
shop the School of Life comm forward
slash shop you'll find lots of
thoughtful books games stationery and
more
you